Speaker 1: last thing, sort of. Tangentially
related to COVID. A number of you sent to me an
extraordinarily disturbing video of failed former
President Donald Trump's former national security
adviser, Michael Flynn, a guy who was, of course,
convicted by after being indicted. Michael Flynn,
it's sort of like it just comes out. He can't even
control it. It's like a diarrhea of the mouth,
an incredible conspiracy word, salad involving
DNA altering COVID shots. And you've all Harari,
the author, wanting to turn people into cyborgs
with robotic components. This is really full on.
And I want you to remember two things. Number one,
at one point, this was the top national security
official in the country, and this is the stuff
that he is now saying. And number two, um, they
continue the the folks that were initially saying
we know the most about this COVID thing continue
to say things this outlandish. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: They are trying to change the very
essence of our DNA. And there are people working
on this. That's one of them. Yuval Noah Harari,
which which is just not going to.
Speaker 1: Work now, by the way,
just as a coincidence, Yuval Noah Harari, who
wrote Sapiens and who wrote Homo Deus and some
other really great books, he just so happens to
be Israeli, right? It just so happens that he's
Jewish. Um, I know that they often criticize.
It's often true that the people they pull into
these conspiracy theories aren't Jewish, but
a whole heck of a lot of them are. And they
mentioned Klaus Schwab and they mentioned
George Soros. And now now Yuval Noah Harari
is the target of it. These people are pathetic.
Speaker 2: So what do they do? They're going to
basically put components of robotics into us.
Well, that's one of the other issues that they
are looking at. So, you know, everything from
you see the robotic arms which can help somebody
or robotic logic which can help somebody who lost
their legs or somebody who lost their movement of
their arm or an arm to be able to do things
in a live like a normal life. But those are
that's different than what these guys are
trying to do. They're actually trying to change
inside the internals of something
that is unchangeable, unmovable,
immovable, because they're designed by
someone other than them. And thank God
that God designed us the way we are.
Speaker 1: You can't even possibly unpack that.
I mean, I'm not even going to try to unpack the
substance of it. That is bonkers stuff. This is a
guy who should be in a psych ward or in prison.
Now, he you know, he was pardoned by Trump. So
he was the national security advisor of the
United States. Understand that. Understand the the
teetering over the brink position that the United
States was in with guys like this. And Trump
claimed he would hire the best people. He needs
professional help and Trump put him at the top
position. For national security in the country.
This guy is leading anyone. We have a serious
problem and now it is just a word. Salad of DNA,
COVID. Yuval Harari, cyborg robotic components.
God designed us. Scary stuff. We should
consider that we dodged a bullet in a sense
that Flynn didn't last that long as National
Security Advisor. Let me know what you think.
Find me on Twitter at Pacman. Remember that the
David Pakman show is a audience, an audience,
I should say, supported program, primarily through
something called the membership program. You can
sign up at join pacman dot com. You can use the
coupon code. Obama Beautiful code. Obama Now
Obama to get a sizable discount. And of course
you will get daily commercial free streams,
audio and video of the show much earlier than we
release them publicly every single day. You'll
also get access to the bonus show, an extra show
every day for our members. And we also are doing
the members only town halls. The most recent one
was a couple of weeks ago, I believe. Sign up at
join pacman icon. Get that discount. Would love
to welcome you into the ranks of membership today.